[Music]
we got to talk about Bachelorette Becca
not to starts coming back I mean I can't
believe it's a returning so soon what
can we expect there's gonna be as much
drama as I think there's gonna be it was
always drama Beth but Becca's awesome I
can't wait for people to actually get to
see her and get to know her as well as
we do everything you think of her at
about ten times - that about how awesome
she is we love her the producers lover
the crew the guys and yeah there will be
drama but it's a great season she's an
awesome Bachelorette we're about I think
a month away what may 28th is our
premiere date how the suit how the guys
stacking up good it's a good group it's
a good group of dudes I'm and I am harsh
I'm a harsh critic of the guys just
because I can be yeah and I'm very
protective of my bachelorettes this is a
good group they are definitely worthy
and I think fingers crossed I mean we're
still shooting so I can honestly say
this do they don't know how it ends
hopefully she's gonna find love so far
has she been taken to a couple of these
guys absolutely yeah no she's falling
you know I think she definitely
sympathizes with Arie now you know I
don't know if she's gonna go down the
same road as Ari but I think she
understands now how that can happen I
mean what an ending really the last
bachelor season as long as you're not
Becca exactly she actually got her due
now it's gonna come out on top believe
me do the damn thing Ari and Lauren
what's our future looking like do you
think Ari and Lauren are doing great
actually just heard from them last week
they just got a house together in
Arizona they were they you know the
after they got off the show they kind of
got off the grid as well went around the
world traveled together and now they're
really just starting a life together
got a house moving in together taking
that first step I love them and wish
them all the best look I get why people
might be mad and angry how it all turned
out but at the end of the day I got to
be happy with two people that are in
love and they're giving it a shot so I'm
happy for them and wish them well
Chris Harrison uses his heart on The
Bachelor and his brain on Who Wants to
Be a Millionaire
et spoke with him at the 2018 Daytime
Emmy Awards where he was nominated for
hosting the game show this is the first
time that I've been nominated his host
and the show was nominated again as well
so it's good validation for us for what
we've done with Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire over the last three years
it's a tough category there any
no nurse at all I mean I'm up against
Pat Sajak Alex Trebek two legends in the
game Steve Harvey Wayne Brady
two guys i admire and know very well so
close i'm happy to be invited to the
dance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]